[Music]
6 Minute English from
bbclearningenglish.com
[Music]
hello this is six minute English from
BBC learning English I'm Neil and I'm
Beth I had my first drive in an electric
car yesterday Neil it was amazing
electric cars are great in theory but
who has the money to buy one it's true
that electric vehicles or EVS as they're
also called are expensive but in some
parts of the world the switch to
electric vehicles has been a major
success story in the fight against
climate change and it's not just rich
people switching to Electric in India
poorer workers are embracing it too yes
in India it's the drivers of small
Vehicles like motorbikes mopeds scooters
and Rick shaes known as two and three
wheelers who dominate the road and now
over half of these are electric
in this program we'll be discussing the
growing role of electric vehicles in the
fight against climate change and as
usual we'll be learning some useful new
vocabulary as well great but first I
have a question for you Neil in India
many different Vehicles use the road but
which country's car market is the
biggest is it a the US B China or C
Japan well I'll guess it's the US that
has the world's largest automobile
Market okay Neil I'll reveal the answer
at the end of the program while electric
vehicles score better than petrol or
diesel cars in most environmental tests
there is some debate about exactly how
green they are a lot depends on how the
electricity is generated in the first
place and in India more than 34 of the
electricity used continues to be
generated by coal nevertheless in India
the transition to Green transport is
well underway here's Louise rebe head of
the climate organization C40 cities
explaining the appeal of EVS to grea
Jackson for BBC World Service program
the climate question what is it about
two and three wheelers that's so
appealing I think it can be summarized
in one word and it's convenience from an
accessibility and affordability an
efficiency point of view and on that
first point of accessibility
the state of public transport is not as
developed as it is in places like London
or Singapore there's no Metro lines or
or fancy bus networks and two and three
wheelers spread in response to this lack
of sufficient or high quality frequent
public transport
infrastructure grer asks why electric
vehicles are so appealing so desirable
and attractive there are several reasons
behind ev's appeal including including
convenience and affordability being
cheap enough for people to buy in places
without reliable public transport
electric scooters are filling the Gap
that's really needed because the massive
increase of petrol cars in Delhi has
created a toxic and very serious health
risk smog smog is air pollution caused
by a mixture of smoke chemicals and
especially car exhaust fumes it makes
the atmosphere difficult to breathe and
very unhealthy what more because
children are smaller and closer to car
exhaust pipes smog affects them most in
Winter the air in Delhi gets so bad they
have to close the schools sometimes for
weeks here's grer Jackson again taking
up the story for BBC World Services the
climate
question they're having to shut schools
because the pollution is so bad gosh
that's hardly a solution is it what can
be done about it
well for India the solution partly lies
in switching to electric scooters and E
Shores by 2030 the government wants 30%
of its vehicles on the road to be
electric and has put up$ 1.2 billion
dollar to make that happen when grer
discusses schools shutting because of
air pollution she uses the word gosh an
expression used to show a strong feeling
of surprise or wonder luckily the Indian
government is taking measures to improve
delhi's air quality largely through the
switch to Greener electric vehicles the
government has put up over1 Billion doar
to make this happen the phrasal verb put
up money for something means to provide
the money needed to pay for it in this
area it seems India is leading the world
which reminds me of your quiz question
Beth that's right I asked you which
country has the world's l lest
automobile market and you said the US
which was the wrong answer I'm afraid
Neil in fact it's now China that tops
the list showing that when it comes to
Green transport bigger isn't always
better right it's time to recap the
vocabulary we've learned in this program
starting with two-wheeler a vehicle with
two wheels such as a bicycle motorbike
or moped the adjective appealing means
attractive desirable or interesting
affordability refers to being cheap
enough for people to buy or in other
words inexpensive smog is air pollution
caused by smoke and car fumes which
makes the atmosphere unhealthy and
difficult to breathe gosh is an
expression used to show a strong feeling
of surprise or wonder and finally if you
put up the money for something you
provide the money needed to pay for it
once again our six minutes are up but
remember to join us again next time time
for more trending topics and useful
vocabulary here at 6 Minute English
goodbye for now
bye 6 minutes English from
bbclearningenglish.com
[Music]